good evening members and uh
and officers
welcome to this annual meeting this
evening thursday the 12th of may 2022
uh welcome also to our youtube viewers
at home as we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording uh my name is
councillor mark hurd and i'm chairman of
morton district council
uh first of all i'd like to warmly
welcome our newest member councillor
paula spensley who was successfully
elected as a liberal democrat
representative for heybridge west last
month my congratulations to you on your
successful campaign paula and i'm
confident you'll properly represent the
good people of haybridge west and the
wider district
thank you chairman
thank you members as uh as you know if
you wish to speak on any item please
indicate and i will invite you to speak
at the appropriate time you may remain
seated if you wish but please reference
a page or paragraph number when
referring to the agenda papers and keep
your contributions clear and concise
please note the sound recording of this
meeting is dependent on the correct use
of microphones
therefore when invited to speak please
turn on your microphone and off when you
finish speaking
by being present in this meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
i would ask you please to avoid
approaching the top part of the table as
the cameras
have live feeds and they are hazardous
i'd also like to advise you that the
fire exit is the door behind this top
table
so agenda item number two is the
election of chairman so members i will
now call for nominations for chairman of
the council for the municipal year to
may 2023 councillor bob boyce thank you
thank you
thank you i'll just just take my eyes to
councillor
shaughnessy first please
um thank you um
chairman i would like to keep the status
quo and i would like to nominate
councillor mark hurd
thank you is there a second and i will
second that
mr chairman are there any other
nominations
any other nominations
i i
answer the boys is it well i said it
germany it works first i did say council
boys is that seconded yes seconded
chairman it was secondary chairman very
beginning okay
a recorded vote is that seconded okay
thank you very much
i'm tara are you able to uh take the
recorded vote please
well i think perhaps we'll strats will
take it as just as names please
what the name of the person you mean yes
the name of the person thank you okay
thank you
um
abstain
voice
[Music]
counselor heard
[Music]
counselor boyce
[Music]
[Music]
heard
counselor heard
[Music]
voice capture stevens
absolute heart
the counselor stills
castle heard
captain flynn
coaster
mrs thompson
that's
boys
thank you very much indeed i will now
invite um councillor boys to take the
chair um as he's doing so
um i would like to thank members for
allowing me the privilege of steering
this council through its most difficult
challenging and turbulent time over the
last two terms
i pay tribute to staff and members
past and present
and their families who were forced to
endure insults and ridicule
by a previous and now disqualified
counsellor
i have nothing but praise for the senior
staff
particularly mr richard holmes
who had been so viciously and unfairly
targeted
he and his colleagues have been
completely exonerated from the spurious
and vexatious allegations made
and i congratulate his patience
and integrity to all those affected
i thank the clerks the civic support
officers and my vice chair councillor
colly mays who have been an invaluable
help to me as has the good advice i've
received from the lga
i hope we can now look forward to
working together
challenging where necessary but without
fear
or malice
so i now hand over to council at pogboys
oh thank you very much
oh dear i've lost oh there it is
um thank you members i think the agenda
item um
uh three is my statutory declaration of
acceptance of office and
it's
very diplomatically blank
oh i've signed it in the wrong place
yes
two signatures
um i
i haven't
made a declaration yet
i uh robert boyce having been elected to
the office of chairman of the council of
the district of malden declared that i
take the office upon myself and will
julie and faithfully fulfill the duties
of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
i undertake to observe the code as to
the conduct which is expected of members
of boldon district council
it is the 12th day
of 5
22
an iso sign
and now
mr dodson's got to sign it
oh
better put this on
it'll rather clash with the other
glitter
[Laughter]
um
right uh a gender item
uh
four is the appointment of um vice
chairman uh and in calling for
nominations
in in calling for the nomination of vice
chairman i propose
counsellor nun
thank you
is there any other nominations
right thank you
uh
now using the precedent set
by my predecessor
vote
um i will um
conduct the two name option that he has
written into the
constitution of the council
i'll try and put this together later it
doesn't work
um miss bird
i uh are you ready to call the role
if you're voting for cats or cancer
swaying or saying when i call you mate
please
abstain
that's the voice
that's a hell
counselor none
counsellor nun please tara that's amazed
councillor swain
councillor none
that's
councillor swain
of that are 18 for councillor none 11
for cancer swaying and two abstentions
thank you
thank you miss bird um councillor nunn
would you like to come up and join me
please
thank you
this isn't um this isn't working it just
different to this
are you ready yet stephen
yeah
i just want that to do good
well thank you very much um for your
confidence uh in me i'll now make the um
declaration
i
stephen peter nunn having been elected
to the office of vice chairman of the
council of the district of malden
declare that i take that office upon
myself and will duly and faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability i
undertake to observe the code of the
code as to the conduct which is expected
of members of malden district council
and i'll sign this and date it with
today's date which is the 12th of may
thank you very much thank you um members
i i thank you um uh for electing me um
to this
position
i
believe the councillor heard
made a very good statement
which i entirely endorse
both to
the conduct
uh and i would i would say that his
conduct the last two years or the last
18 months
uh has been extraordinary
he he has worked
at times under extreme pressure which i
know from
an earlier
history i also
echo his
congratulations to councillor spencer
i think you're the first liberal
democrat here for 27 years
welcome
um
i
i also
will try to be a political in this
chamber
i will
discontinue any association
with the conservative group however
because of the 1989
local government and housing act due to
the
proportion
political balances i will remain a
member of the conservative group
um i think the vice chairman would like
to say something yes thank you mr
chairman um i echo those sentiments i'm
still an independent non-aligned
counsellor and i will certainly not be
joining any political group and i would
not be showing any political bias thank
you
right can we move on to agenda item six
apologies for absence i believe we've
got a full house miss bird
thank you very much
um item seven declaration of interest
to declare the existence and nature of
any person or personal and prejudicial
interest relating to items on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs eight to
twelve inclusive of the code of conduct
for members
members are reminded that they are also
require required to declare interest as
soon as they
become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting
is there any declarations councillor
dharam
uh chairman yes um although there
doesn't appear to be anything on the
agenda
um particularly relating to essex county
council i declare non-cunary interest as
a member of that authority
council fleming
uh a non-binary as a member of essex
county council if anything crops up
thank you chairman councillor stamp
oh you can see me all the way back here
can you chairman because i'm usually at
the front when you're in the chair oh my
lord excited but i know you're there
somewhere
i'm also a member of essex county
council non-pecuniary there's nothing on
the agenda tonight that i think is uh
going to affect us thank you bye any
other member
right we'll go on to agenda item eight
minutes of the 31st of march 22
on pages 7-20
and we confirm the minutes of the
meeting
held
on the 31st of march
and this is for accuracy only um i think
again the precedent that the previous
chairman has set up is that he doesn't
go through it by page to page but ask
members if there is any
um inaccuracies they'd like to raise
councillor fluker
thank you chairman and then can i also
pay tribute to councillor herd as well
for the the extraordinary good work he
did that during these meetings over the
last two years um chairman um
page 18 paragraph three um i i seem to
remember that there was some
sort of confusion around leaders
questions last time
and and and the chairman was incredibly
pragmatic by allowing members to carry
on asking questions uh and and the
answers wouldn't be given by a written
response well in paragraph three
chairman i i can see it's been counter
circle what was the minute number oh
well it's it's page 18 chairman it will
be minute number 15
but i've referenced it to the page
number because it's a long minute so for
your benefit i've said page 18
and it's actually paragraph three and
it's prefixed with my salutation name
germans asking this question but my
point is chairman is and we are only
talking about accuracy here i asked the
question the chairman had already ruled
that answers would be given in writing
although
the the leader did respond but clearly
not when you read to this to the
question i asked i mean the question i
asked was why had no member given
evidence that the public inquiry that
was not answered so chairman
whether or not clark's got time to check
this now i i don't suppose she has but i
would like to have a written response to
that chairman
can we um
as you say that we might need to refer
to
miss bird
but
can we look at that
and give you a written response what
well chairman that that is what the
direction of the chairman was to the
leader and that clearly didn't answer my
question so it is a matter of accuracy
and i'm quite happy to wait for my
response but i don't like it thank you
um any other uh issues with minutes
do we accept these by acclimation
thank you
um
chairman's announcements
i've i have not been advised um that
anybody
uh of any chairman's um announcements
but i'm sure there will be some to come
in the future councillor heard is there
anything you wish to refer to
um
thank you
um
then we go on to
item 10 minutes of the meetings of the
council which is one two three four five
committee meetings there is there any
questions on any of those
items
no agreed the minutes
thank you
now we come to notice emotions a point
of order chairman thank you
um which rule are we breaking uh
chairman i i i know what a wily old [ __ ]
[ __ ]
withdraw that i'd better withdraw that i
mean
um yeah i
did just to rewind chairman and marisa i
know what a wiley old fox you are but
i'd like to think that you think me as
uh as as a a widely young fox um
chairman
the uh the rule i refer to chairman and
i know you on there well it's uh
procedural form in particular wall four
three and chairman with that in mind i'd
respectfully ask that with the
permission of
the chairman and the leader and for the
convenience to dispatch the business you
allow the motions to be dealt with at
this meeting however
i am mindful chairman that there may
well be a political will in this chamber
that these uh motions are deferred and i
think bearing in mind the amount of
business we need to get through tonight
that might be the right and proper thing
to do
are you
with me chairman i'm i'm i'm i'm
following you right okay so you're not
asking me to no i'm not i'm i rule i i'm
asking you
not to do that but i i what i've
actually said also
um is that i know there's a political
will to uh to dispatch these motions to
committees which i think is going to
elongate the procedure but i'm prepared
chairman to uh
put to you and hopefully you'll accept
this
the the the motions so proposed in
particular motion what number one
is referred to the joint standards
committee and the council agrees to call
the meeting of that meet a meeting of
that committee within 10 working days
and chairman with regards to motions
two and four
they are referred to the strategy and
resources committee on the 25th of may
which is a couple of weeks time chairman
and i'm sure that would work and as far
as the uh motion three it's referred to
pga on the ninth of june and of course
on those days chairman i i can exercise
my right to speak to the motion at those
committees under the uh terms of the
rules of procedure
thank you councillor fluker we're all in
uh uh uh
you and
i are in agreement uh certainly with
that procedure of referring these
motions to the relevant committees which
is
joint standards committee one
um
snr two i think pga 3 and snr4
yes um i've got council stamp first then
councillor sizzle chairman i don't agree
with it this has been brought to this
council for this meeting
and yes
you know the rule very well but i don't
think in the spirit of what this is
written it should go to those committees
it's come to full council to be debated
and agreed and voted on and i think it'd
be a very unfair decision to actually
change it now thank you chairman
councillor uh thank you chairman uh for
something to go to joint standards
committee has to go through a set
process
um and that process cannot be done in 10
days so that is again an unreasonable uh
motion or request that the
council fluker is putting forward
well that would be my ruling uh
uh members
uh well i'm i'm not a seed into you i'm
just following
our constitution
um
chairman can it not go to a vote
no uh councillor stan um
the the
you wish to say something mr kwelsh
wishes to make comment
um yeah thank you chairman um under rule
four of the procedure rules
these have automatically
gone to committee there's a discretion
the chairman not to obviously the
chairman hasn't exercised that
discretion so they've automatically gone
to committee
[Applause]
there's nothing in the rules that start
specifying dates now members could bring
a motion if the chairman agrees because
it's relevant to the subject that
that
a particular motion is dealt with or if
considered by committee in a certain
time
but a motion would have to be put that
would have to be seconded the chairman
would have to accept that motion because
it's not specifically in the rules
about time limits for dealing with
matters referred to committee but that
would require a motion to the next
council meeting we can't deal with that
this evening
mr gross
it's it's it's your ruling normally
um
normally chairman rule 4 says that there
has to be
it has to be in the preceding week
of the
council meeting obviously if you think
that emotion is relevant to a particular
item that's already come up
and you think it's all part of it you
can deal with that motion orally now
that's a matter for you chairman
uh councillor thompson
thank you chairman um i was just going
to say that as regards the motion that
could potentially go to jsc it wouldn't
follow the normal procedure of a
complaint as far as i can see um
with mr welch's confirmation if you'd
like to ask him for it i mean this is
simply a report to jsc for them to deal
with in the same way they do other
procedural matters um not a complaint
against an individual because there's no
name
um yeah or even indicated
jsc does deal with other matters
that are not
related to complaints isn't that so mr
close chairman that's correct um so it
would be appropriate for this to go
um to the next meeting the jsc there
would need not need to be a
um a long process
um
anybody else want to disagree with me
okay right onto a gender item
uh 12.
is
um
yeah
mr quilt has pointed out that
council of fluker
uh said within 10 days
um
but
uh
as far as i'm concerned
in in a timely manner it will be
referred to
the relevant committees
okay
um
agenda item 12
questions in accordance with procedure
rule 6 2 of which notice has been given
um i take it miss bird there's been no
such
thank you
uh gender item 13 leaders and
composition of political groups
uh which are to follow it says and i
think
they've been
online and little one is to consider the
reported director of strategy
performance and governance on the
leaders and compositions of each
political group
which um
we we will um
look at
has anybody got paper copies
this is a gender item 13 and uh it's a
summary of issues
as required by the local government
housing act 89
um the strategy and performance
governance manager has been notified
that the composition of the political
groups on the council are as follows
uh and
they are uh obviously
uh there that is a matter of fact so we
note that do we
thank you then to little two that the
council considers the ratification of
the leader designate as leader of the
council now i've got a bit of a problem
with this because we've got an in-situ
leader
and a leader designate uh which is
council siddal
um
so i think
i'll um follow councillor herds
president again and take both names
together
is that okay
you need to consider there is a leader
designated
the first decision is whether that's
ratified by council
so that will be your first issue if it's
not ratified oh i'm changing i'm i'm
using rule 23 okay to come to the same
conclusion
um
i mean is this acceptable to youth
council
i think it would be the fairest way of
dealing with it i think yeah
yeah okay that's that's no problem
um
right uh
miss bird no you still need nominations
oh uh i've got no
i'm told i need nominations so we'll go
back
to ratify the leader designate which is
uh councillor citadel and we'll take a
vote
on whether councillor civil is ratified
as a leader
no
yes we're going backwards
uh well because uh the monitoring
officer is advising me i can't do it the
way i want to do it
the
the procedure rules talk about at the
annual meeting
first one of the first matters of
business is ratification the leader
designate counter signal councillor
siddal is the leader designate however
the chairman is correct
ultimately there is rule the final rule
in the procedure rules gives the
chairman discretion on how he runs the
meeting that's absolutely right so if
the chairman says i'm not going to
follow that i'm i'm actually going to
call for nominations on leader then
obviously that's within
his domain to do that because he's the
final arbiter of the rules and final
arbiter of what happens in this council
meeting but the actual procedure rules
talk about
ratifying the leader designate
right so
councillor thompson
so i'd like to nominate councillor penny
channel oh and uh councillor mays
well can we ratify the ratification of
the nomination
i will i will second um councillor
siddal if someone can then second
councillor channel
right so we have two we had two not we
we
we had two nominations that have been
proposed and julie seconded uh miss bird
can you
um
are you speaking councillor
thank you council fluker did you want to
join in this bit of fun gemini i i i i
can i say it's a shame i'm standing up
so it's not so enjoyable when you're
standing up but what what perhaps the uh
perhaps the monitoring officer just put
me back in my comfort zone and asked me
why and let me know exactly what happens
to a general item 13
roman 2 because that's on the agenda so
surely we need to do something with that
before we do something else yeah it
doesn't um you know
it feels a little bit odd but and and
i'm i'm totally concerned that the
chairman is using these advanced powers
in the back of the constitution and i
hope these aren't
made habitually i'm trying to get the
meeting
um
through in a proper orderly manner and
there is uh an are not an
anachronism here um because i don't
think the agenda item is correctly uh
worded
so i'm going to have to rule
as i've ruled miss bird
now uh again if you wish the leader to
be councillor siddal you say councillor
civil if you wish the leader to be
counsellor chana you say councillor
chana
miss bird
yes chairman
and then the chamber said if you just
indicate council mrs chandler council or
extension when i came on please please
staffing me pass the bachelor degree by
state
that's mrs
councilor mrs channer councillor
that's amaze
everyone's got the lights
i've got the lights on so tara can
actually hear
councillor channel
[Music]
councillor
thank you tara
[Music]
i declare mrs chana is the leader of the
council
and continues to be so and we come to
little three now that the council elects
the deputy leader of the council can i
have nominated mrs thompson please
i've got councillor
thompson
uh
um and all second counselor siddal
right
um recorded vote please
is that seconded yeah
um
miss bird would you do the honours again
please
yes
thompson sorry others
councillor mrs thompson
councillor thompson
councillor mrs thompson
councillor siddall
thompson
council mrs thompson
councillor
councillor thompson
councillor thompson
councillor thompson
[Music]
councillor
councillor
epstein
councillor mrs thompson
councillor siddall
councillor
councillor
you need to ask
her counselor mrs thompson
i declare that uh councillor thompson is
deputy leader councillor siddal
uh thank you chairman uh uh yeah i'm
quite disheartened by that because
uh
just a few minutes ago you and
councillor none announced that you would
not be political and in those votes you
have just demonstrated that you are
political
uh well thank you for that observation
um you're saying that the chairman and
vice chairman have no right to vote
and i do not accept that
um
we now go on to
was that little
we now do little one recommendation yes
uh the the allocation of seats on
committees are set out in section 3.6
below be ratified i think this is just a
statement of facts
the the members nominations set out in
appendix a be approved i've got no idea
what appendix a is
yeah uh so we accept that then
uh little three
um where nominations have not been
received to appoint members to these
committees positions council uh
channel
um
thank you chairman
um does that mean um when it says that
chairman that where nominations have not
been received to appoint members to
these committee positions
is that to do with non-aligned um
positions if that is so chairman um then
i would like i don't know if it's the
correct time but i do have proposals um
to ensure that those committee positions
are filled by the the non-aligned um
which as i believe the requirement of
this authority um and that we have to do
it at this council meeting because um
they have to be done at the council
meeting chairman because the names like
those of the other groups are not on the
order paper and i'm happy to make a
proposal if you so wish chairman across
the street please do so if it's going to
help facilitate matters
thank you
uh yes also we would like to nominate
amazon right well that's that's fair
enough
uh council swain did you
yes chairman before we move on to um
populating the committees um i'd um like
to just raise with members the question
of uh how it is done
the um that there is some ambiguity
certainly in the legislation about
what a political group is and we're
quite clear that we have to have
political balance
um which then presumes everybody's in a
group which obviously they're not
aligned and not they're not a group and
they're not organized they don't have a
leader um
but but clearly the distribution of
seats has got to provide for them to
have a proportional number of places
where the legislation does help is that
when it refers to replacing members
uh the replacement should be agreed with
with by the group
i think we're replacing so uh what i
would like to suggest that we take some
discussion and advice on is whether the
non-aligned members
to go on these committees should be
elected by and from within the
non-aligned group and there should not
be any influence from other political
groups on their representation
that
what we're looking at at the moment at
3.6 is is just the proportional
seat allocation to each committee
um for example the p
performance governance and audit is four
independents four conservatives and two
non-aligned that is all we're looking at
at the moment
um
the the
uh
1989 local government and housing act
uh sets out the provisions uh to do this
and you have to populate all the
committees as near as possible to the
percentage
of
um
their numbers
uh within the uh within the council so
at the moment i don't think there's a
contentious issue
what might happen and i think which you
you may be referring to is when we go on
to populate the committees with
non-aligned
okay is that the correctness i think
that's where we are
now no no
no no
has got
uh a list so uh mrs chandler if you'd
like to yes chairman i might just ask
are you happy for me to go across the
whole suite of the committees
please at this stage do and i'll ask you
to do the same in a
if we've got a nomination
that's duly seconded that duly proposed
and seconded
which i think uh mrs channel you
proposed was that second did yes it was
it was uh so if this proposal is carried
by a majority then we won't need to look
at councillor civil's list
surely that's undemocratic well yeah
yeah you can't have a person who just
because they spoke first has first dips
oh well you you can add first dibs if
you like
and uh
chairman i understand
are you ignoring some advice from the
monitoring officer
the procedure
out things yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
need to follow that up with me okay um
mrs channel give us your names for the
performance governance and audit right
you want me to do just um singularly all
right okay tim for performance
government audit then chairman i propose
that to sit on that committee are
councillors fluker and stamp
is that second it
okay
do you want to do this vote by vote
mrs channel what's the
strategy and resources strategy and
resources chairman is councillors fluka
stamp and lagan
um is anybody taking a note of this
um yes
okay thank you
um
licensing
um yes chairman uh councillors helm and
none
overview and scrutiny council spencer
and helm
joint standards
counsellors numb and helm
investigating and disciplinary
counselor helm
inve investigating and disciplinary
panel counsellors lagan and stamp
appointments board um
you want me to give the names for two
members because it's political um
balance chairman
yeah we'll come we'll come back to that
right there's a set of proposals that
were proposed and julie seconded i'll
now take a uh a vote uh on that
chairman chairman tara said can you slow
down she hasn't got it all written down
please
yeah we've got i've got to take the
alternative nominations
uh
first
i'm not allowed to do it the easy way
council seattle
performance and governance uh thank you
chairman so on performance and
governments i nominate councillor
spenceley
uh just one nomination just one
nomination okay
um
strategy and resources council
especially
uh
licensing no i have no further
nominations chairman right thank you oh
that does um
council especially
i don't agree to go on to performance
and gov performance and governance
or strategy of resources
okay
exactly that that leaves yeah
just licensing i think you were
nominated for as well
and um
no ovian scrutiny chairman
spence councillor spencer helm i had for
open scrutiny oh
well that's outside of my list
um
can somebody
tell me whether there's now
any conflict with mrs chana's list
um
your name i think was nominated for uh
what was it mrs janet
yeah i would prefer to do over i want
overview and scrutiny okay of the three
thank you that's a proper place for
opposition to be
um
so so therefore mrs tanner's
list there's no conflict to members
agree
thank you
it's been determined by the council
council slain
um
right
uh we've got to come back to the
appointments board which we can't do yet
can we
no
right
um
yes
thank you chair looking around the room
a lot of people are looking very puzzled
people around me are saying what's going
on and i'm saying what's going on i
don't understand what we've just done
could you explain it to me please sorry
thank you we have
to appoint members to the various
committees of the council
we have nominations from the two
political groups which stand alone and
can't be challenged
the council's constitution says
individuals that are not a member of any
group
have to be appointed to committee places
by the council
which is effectively what we've just
done
does that help
yes it does i'm i'm happy with that
thank you i don't understand the rest of
the committee positions or are we about
to come to that please thank you
um
the the rest of the committee positions
the only ones that haven't been decided
uh we've got we've got the jsc and um
uh
uh which we've all agreed
i think the the appointments called the
appointments board is done by
um
uh positions rather than uh no plus two
yes plus two which somebody will tell me
in a minute
what the political balance is uh because
once you've got the leader the uh the
opposition leader
um
and the chairman of the closest uh of
strategy and resources and pga
um that will leave i think by the by the
looks of it two
um
non-aligned people to a point to that
position
council schemes
uh yes uh forgive my confusion too but
as i'm looking at this list so for
example we
we have already then appointed all
members of the major committees is that
what you're saying and that's according
to the list that we've been circulated
uh but uh chairs and vice chairs have
have been appointed in accordance with
the conservatives
we go into
so in short just to be just looking at
the first list on that on the
performance governance and audit the
following member which members are now
on that or everybody listed on here or
not
yes yeah so
that's seven plus four plus four
no
one says one non-aligned
and
so which the two not aligned
and the other ones stand all right thank
you right
uh right mr cross we now
uh we now got little four
uh purposes substitute serbian
performance governance and nordic
members are allowed to sit on the
overview and scrutiny committee this
this is um
a sensible
um
recommendation
i think to allow substitutes
before
it was decided
that
um if you was
a member of the overview and scrutiny
you couldn't sit on
the main
committees or if you was a member of the
overview
if you were a member of the strategy and
resources or the pga you couldn't sit on
overview and scrutiny and it meant
sometimes
that
people couldn't turn up and other other
members couldn't be substituted so
providing that the chairman
um i think mrs channel isn't that right
we're looking at little four
for the the substitute rule
that's correct
that is correct it's because at the
moment um you can't populate with
substitutes because if you sit on vga
and snr you're not allowed to go on to
rns and we've found that what's occurred
chairman because of that ruling
sometimes ons finds itself with not
sufficient numbers or
uh because people might not be able to
attend and they can't place um again a
substitute this allows
um those that do sit on pga
and
snr to attend the substitutes
uh so this this is a this is a change of
our constitution uh to change a rule
um do members agree that
okay thank you uh now we come to uh our
guests i think
little five
oh sorry uh councillor mayes
oh yeah thank you mr chairman um i i
don't actually agree with the uh last
proposal and i'd like to uh have my uh
recorded again yes please thank you you
got that miss bird it was and and uh uh
misspell as well
oh councillor bell i'm sorry
um
to a point
parish town councillors for the joint
service of the joint standards uh
committee
uh from the list of three nominees
sent to uh all members on the ninth of
may i think we have two uh
mr todd councillor todd is it
from mayland
and councillor pullman from malden town
council
um
there's there's three nominations
you need members to vote on two out of
those three councillor swain
um just can i make a comment that um
i think it is uh
very important and we're not usually
able to do this to have a representative
from
the villagers as opposed to um entirely
from either malden or burnham
yeah well that's why we got
one from mayland
which is a village i think
chairman
remember it's really intense
um
mr krause will tell me i've got to take
each member and
vote
councillor todd
those in favor of councillor todd please
show
well that looks pretty
unanimous i don't think i need to count
those in favor of councillor pullman
please show
unless you do each seat individually
all right i've got to go back again
nobody tells you these things beforehand
i've got to go back and um
uh count all those in favor of uh
councillor todd please show again
of council perlman
yeah now you can only have two votes
members and we have another um
applicant who's not actually here and
that's councillor shrimpton
um
council pullman
i'll allow you to talk which you're not
a member of the council but
that's
thank you for that
um i'll i'll i won't vote any further
uh and so therefore countless ways
mike
but i'd just like to point out there is
a provision in the constitution
how you deal with three nominations yeah
well we would do we was going we was
going through that process
no it's not the process in the
constitution yes it is because uh um i
now
thanks to you got to embarrass somebody
those in favor of councillor shrimpton
kneeled points
uh
so councillors todd and uh pullman are
now
um appointed to the joint standards
committee thank you very much
where we got to now i think we're
adjourning now
yeah uh right i'll now adjourn the
meeting for
um
the
uh um
dummy
uh committees rather for the committees
to actually appoint their their chairman
and and and vice chairman and um
somebody will call out the names
of each committee
uh and
uh i think if it would be helpful if
you've stood
um for this uh process uh so
we can see
um
mr uh dodson
um is it actually
teaching pg a first
yes chairman
it's councillor edwards
councillor schemes
councillor stevens
councillor mrs stiltz
counselor mrs fleming
councillor hull
councillor keys councillor mrs thompson
councillor fluka and councillor stamp
right
i'll now call for nominations for
chairman
councillors winston
sorry councillor councillor
uh is that seconded
thank you
is there any other nominations counselor
do this standing up and sitting down a
bit together um could i nominate
councillor jeanette stiltz please
i'll second that right thank you
um
can i uh
call for a vote
on councillor stamp please
one two three four
five six
those against
one two three four therefore councillor
stamp is elected chairman over to you uh
council stamp
um thank you chairman thank you members
um i would now i'd like to thank
everybody for voting for me and
congratulate you on your position and
the vice chair as well um i'd now call
for nominations for the position of vice
chair of the performance governance and
audit committee and i would like to
nominate from the chair councillor jane
fleming can i be seconder
seconded thank you do i have any other
nominations please i'd like to nominate
councillor ed
seconder
okay
chairman do i continue can i have a show
of hands please for councillor jane
fleming to be the vice chair of pgna
show of hands those against
um i congratulate am i doing this right
chairman you can pick me up um i
congratulate councillor joan fleming
sorry
i counted six
six and four six and four
thank you
i congratulate councillor jane fleming
who is now the vice chair of pg a uh and
there are no no other business chairman
so i'd like to close this committee
meeting and i thank everybody in the
members thank you
um thank you council sam um mr dodson
yes strategy resources
are councillor bassinger
councillor shaughnessy
councillor siddal
councillor
swain councillor mrs channer
councillor durham
councillor mrs thompson
councillor white
councillor fluka
councillor stamp and councillor lagan
i now call for nominations for chairman
of strategy and resources
i'll second that chairman any other
nominations councillor shawnee
is that seconded yes
thank you
um uh
i therefore um
uh called for votes on
um
who was the chairman
those in favor
one two three four five six seven
those against
one two three four
i therefore declare councillor white is
chairman and hand over to her thank you
mr chairman
for me and i'm delighted to accept the
petition of the chair of the strategy
resources committee
and i would like to call the nominations
of the vice chairman and from the chair
i would like to host councillor dorad
thank you
i would like to uh
one two three four five six seven
and all those in between council
yes chairman
it's councillor bassinger
councillor siddall
councillor stevens
councillor mrs stiltz
councillor durham
councillor hull
councillor morgan
councillor mrs thompson
councillor helm and councillor none
i'd like to call for nominations for
chairman of licensing chairman i
propose councillor durham is that
seconded
any other nominations
i declare councillor
durham is chairman thank you very much
chairman thank you members uh so members
from the chair um i seek nominations for
the position of vice chair
of the licensing committee
and i would like to nominate councillor
morgan for that position
are there any other nominations
councillor morgan is therefore elected
as the vice chairman of the licensing
committee and i close the meeting
here with thank you
mr dodson um overview and scrutiny
that's counselor bill
councillor bell
council of brian beale
councillor bell councillor heard
councillor mays
councillor miss beale
councillor hubner
councillor morgan
councillor morley
councillor spenceley and councillor helm
thank you um i call for nominations
for chairman of overview and scrutiny
council morley
i'll second though thank you any other
nominations
is that second lift
thank you councilman secondly by
councillor molly
um dozing
sorry
maze i knew it began with a name
is that is that dazzling dress you've
got on
right um i now call for a vote on uh
councillor helm
mr chairman
one two three four five
those against
one two
three
thank you
oh i'm sorry uh councillor bill
uh poor against in my abstention
i i declare uh councillor helm as
chairman
thank you mr chair sean um i call for
nominations for vice chair and from the
chair i'd like to nominate councillor
spenceley
and we have a vote for
councillor spencer please
one two three four five
that's one two three four five six
always remember to vote for yourselves
and i called for votes for councillor at
maze wasn't it
one two
three
three
so count suspenseless vice chairman
thank you very much
mr dodson's joint standards committee
okay joint standards members are
councillor bassinger
councillor mays councillor stevens
councillor miss beale councillor mrs
fleming councillor mrs thompson
councillor nunn
councillor helm
and councillor michael perlman and
councillor nigel todd
you're quite welcome to join the
committee
you're you're there in an advisory
capacity
um
uh can i call for uh chairman of um
joint standards committee please
councillor fleming please
uh any other nominations
is that seconded
right thank you
those in favor
of
council fleming
one two three four five those against
two three
i therefore declare council flaming
chairman
thank you chairman from the chair i seek
nominations for vice chair
and from the chair i nominate councillor
nunn
do i have any other nominations
okay so i call for a vote
yes please
okay i nominate councillor nunn
all right okay let's have the vote
okay for councillor none
five and against
awful councillor passenger
councillor mays sorry
okay so councillor nunn is elected as
vice chair thank you i closed the
meeting
investigating and disciplinary committee
councillor mays
councillor siddall councillor mrs chana
councillor hubner and councillor helm
can i call
five is that correct can i call for
nominations for chairman
uh i nominate chairman uh councillor
bruce hubner please exact second leg
i'll second that
um any other nominations
counsellor said oh please
well done
um
i i i therefore call for a vote
one two three
uh
three those against
two
uh councillor houdini's chairman
thank you
a second mr chairman i will nominate
councillor mates
on our second myself
carry on thank you chair
um
the vice chairman
thank you
um we now go to the district planning i
don't think it would be necessary for
members um uh to stand um uh for this um
do we need to call out the names of
members of
just everything just everyone
everybody's on there yeah okay
um
i in calling for a chairman i nominate
uh councillor lagan
i second that chairman any other
nominations
that second
right
um so we will need to do a vote all
those in favor of councillor lagos
over to you uh miss bird
[Music]
today councilman
[Music]
council amaze
counselor lagan
yes
[Music]
mm
lagging
abstain
councillor maze
is chairman of um
uh district planning over to you
councillor lagan uh thank you thank you
chair um i'd now like to call for the
appointment of the vice chairman of the
committee for the ensuing municipal year
and from the chair i'd like to call
councillor bruce hubena can i have a
second to please
take a did counsellor stamp
any other
vote
nominations
tara could we uh undertake the recorded
voters the same protocols as before
please
[Music]
[Music]
councillor hubner
councillor hubler
councillor hubner
councillor hubena
councillor maze
[Music]
council
amaze
counselor maze
councillor mays
councilman hubner
councillor hubler please tara
oh sorry i was i was away there i was i
was just remarking in my head it's like
cancer morgan's projection of his voice
and uh yes so i declare that counselor
hoover knew he's the vice chair of the
district planning committee and there's
no other business being present i hereby
close the meeting sorry
um right thank you uh
central area planning committee
mr dodson
councillor edwards
councillor heard
councillor mays
councillor shawnessy councillor mrs
stiltz
councillor swain
councillor miss beale
councillor hubner
councillor lagan
councillor nunn and councillor spencer
can i call for nominations for chairman
of central
proposal
carly mays seconds
any other nominations i propose
counselor and bill
seconded
can i have a show of hands those in
favor of counselor mates
one two three four five six
those against
one two
three
i therefore got four sorry i therefore
declare that councillor mays is gem do
you obviously
council mates uh thank you mr chairman
um as the newly elected um chairman of
central area planning i now move to
appoint a vice chairman of the committee
for the ensuing municipal year
i would like to nominate councillor flo
shaughnessy are there any other
nominations please
thank you any other nominations please
second that thank you
all those in favor of councillor
shaughnessy please raise your hands
one two three four five
six
all those in favor of councillor lagan
please raise your hands
one two three
is that three
one two three
four
i can't so so sorry i can't see you up
there
um thank you i therefore declare that uh
councillor shawnessy is the new vice
chairman
and i closed the meeting at uh 2052.
thank you
meeting the northwestern area planning
committee mr dodson please
councillor
councillor stevens
councillor durham
councilman mrs fleming
councillor
keys councillor morgan
councillor morley
councillor mrs thompson
councillor white
can i call for nominations for chairman
eliminator
other nominations
um
therefore councillor thompson your
elected chairman would like to take over
please thank you chairman thank you very
the absence of any other nominations
quite if they're with
councillor and apologize please
as vice chairman of northwestern
planning for the consuming eligible year
and there'll be no further business i
could buy posts
um
thank you members will
now sorry
oh southeast
i was ahead of myself um mr dodson
southeast
chairman
councillor bassinger councillor brian
beale
councillor bell councillor schemes
councillor boyce councillor mrs channer
councillor hull
councillor dewick
councillor helm
can i have nominations for chairman of
southeast please counselor mark
bassinger
is that second in mrs tanner
mark bassinger
right thank you uh those in favor of
councillor duik please show
seven
those against
one two
three four i therefore declare council
of europe as chairman
thank you chairman thank you members
uh
from i call for nominations for vice
chairman of the committee and from the
chair i'd like to propose council fluker
that seconded i'll second that thank you
any other nominations
is that second
um
and uh therefore i called for a vote uh
those in favor of councillor fluka
please show
three four five six
and those against
one two three four
therefore cancer fluker is appointed as
vice chairman of the committee for the
current municipal year and there being
no further business i closed the meeting
thank you chairman thank you
members we can now resume at uh about
four minutes to nine i think
um
uh and then we go on to 17 appointment
of representatives
oh oh we've got to go back to the
appointments board
what are the names we have uh mrs
chandler
yeah
how many am i how many is it because
it's politically balanced chairman
uh mr dodson
yes but
based on those um positions that are
filled by the the statutory roles
there are to be nominated one
independent
and one non-aligned member
um chairman um
the leader of the council
is automatically
appointed the opposition leader
and the chairman of the strategy and
resources and the performance governance
audit committees so then there are two
other named members to be
okay
added
i will nominate councillor mays
um
but that is quite clear then there's
two nominations one independent and one
non-aligned um
i therefore
do we agree that they
they'd be appointed to the appointments
right thank you
um now mr quilts can i carry on you can
thank you
um
appointments to of representatives to
local government and outside bodies um
now again uh mrs channel mr uh council
said sorry um have you got any sort of
agreement on this
yes chairman we do have agreement apart
from one which is the local highways
panel where there have we haven't come
to an agreement um and yeah i would
therefore like straight away like
someone eight councillor michael edwards
or central
um okay um
uh mrs chana our second yeah
um
chairman i don't is that are you are you
agree
with that is that's the only contention
no um i'm afraid chairman i thought we
were giving three names each and i gave
three names and my proposals are as on
the order paper chairman when i can find
it um
and i believe i put
um councillor nunn i believe and i
believe councillor morgan
and councillor hull that covers the
three areas so what is the conflict then
councillor
sorry
so
we feel that as we are the largest group
on central planning
therefore the representation should come
from the largest group on central
planning the positions on the locals
highways panel relate to or tend to
relate to the planning committees as we
are the largest group on the central
planning committee we feel that it's
fair that the representative from the
central planning committee is an
independent group member
councillor none is not an independent
group member so therefore we feel that
it is but the the council protocol i
should think on this of having one from
each i don't know whether it's a
resolution one from each area committee
we have we have got a nomination uh from
the leader of the council and we've got
a nomination from the uh opposition
leader so it's a straightforward vote on
these two names councillor edwards
i also like to nominate cancer richard
siddall on the local highways panel um
i've
i'm i'm confused i thought there was
only one not totally
i'll second that thank you oh
well i've done three chairmen i did
three on the second did
right um
yeah yeah um we have
i can take this two ways i can take each
name
uh in turn or i can take the
uh leader's proposition and put that to
the council which i think is probably
the most equitable
thing to do
um so
the leaders proposition is councillors
um it was councillors hull for southeast
it was councillor none for central and
it was councillor morgan
for northwest area if you want to do it
like that chairman uh would members uh
like to vote uh recorded vote please
secondly
um miss bird
over to you again
four
against
again
[Music]
i vote for
against
thank you
the leader's proposition is carried
um
we can now resume
oh yeah we've got um
outside bodies
that was the only one in contention i
was advised
um a appointment of members to serve on
working groups of the council
agenda item 18.
um
is there um is there any agreement
between
so therefore council agree
thank you
uh annual report of the overview and
scrutiny committee
um
uh was that um
councillor stilts do you want to
oh councillor bella i'm sorry
councillor and i would thank you very
much mr chairman like to speak briefly
on that um
it has been an absolute pleasure to
serve as chair of
overview and scrutiny for the last year
we've worked very hard
and we've uh
we've done some good work i think we've
unpicked quite a lot of issues some of
the items that have been proposed for
scrutiny have turned out to be um
requests for information so the working
group system has worked very well i
think in filtering those
so people can read for themselves the um
yeah the issues that we've scrutinized
i'd just like to say that this report
since this report was produced there
have has been some further information
particularly councillor white's issue is
i believe still open
but i dare say my successor councillor
helm will take that forward
of course
and just thank you
thank you miss bell uh councillor siddal
thank you chairman i would just like to
commend the work that
uh councillor bell and mays have done in
turning around the overview and scrutiny
committee and it was my original idea
that we have a working group that
filtered suggestions to that committee
which seems to have worked because in
the previous year i think virtually
every single overview and security
committee was cancelled because the
chairman decided there wasn't any
business and i'm glad that's now changed
and i hope that new chairman changes his
attitude towards the overview and
scrutiny committee and keeps it running
rather than cancelling meetings which is
what you did previously
rather like the council of snr committee
meetings councillor white
thank you mr chairman i'd like to thank
councillor bell with the help with the
item that i've been looking into and i'm
absolutely positive that councillor helm
will continue the good work as he has
previously um i've always found the over
in scrutiny committee be very good and
very helpful so thank you
thank you uh councillor bell um a very
good report
and and a verbal one
um we now go on the general chairman i
should probably have thanked officers
for their support with that report i do
it goes without saying refusely thank
you
uh agenda item 20 southeastern area
planning committee
oh i'm sorry yes yeah agreed
um
the debate
uh councillor channel would you like to
uh introduce this
um thank you very much chairman i'm
having difficulty scrolling on my um
equipment so kindly um council of nuns
let me see his um chairman
his papers
um
yes chairman um i'm sure members will
recall um the debate in the chamber
recently at the last meeting and we did
say that at this same um at this
statutory annual we would like an update
to come forward
and the purpose of this
report is to um
determine the feasibility of the setup
and support of the live streaming from
burnham town council members are very
keen on the order paper chairman there
are um three um there's three thank you
options yes there's three options jim
sorry just scrolling up because i'm
losing it and then the summary of the
key issues chen which i don't know that
i really need to go over again and
actually on the order paper chairman of
very details options for members to see
um and i will see if i can get mine
going now
um because i don't know what's going on
here right um
yes thank you chairman i'll see you next
jumped again i don't know what's
happening
um sorry
if i could just go down sorry
yeah so the summary key of issues and i
want to draw members attention to the
appendix
uh because there's on the appendix a
variety of options now chairman i'm not
going to pretend that i fully understand
the technical detail of these options
but they're all detailed and give
members the pros and cons on appendix a
and also chairman what i would say is
there's a breakdown when you go through
there's an explanation behind every
option the equipment that could be
installed or not and then chairman
lowered down on the report
you'll see benefits
there's risks and overall suitability
and then there's a table regarding the
options chairman showing all the
financial
um if you like a summary there showing
which um you know the costs associated
with it ongoing costs as well chairman
and then there's the feature the feature
rating which lists all those options
i've just referred to six in all and
you'll see the table there which clearly
shows at the moment that option four and
there's option five b have got all green
so but uh the officers report recommends
um
option four if we go down that line and
if i just read them out chairman i'll
i'll read them out that probably the
best way if i read the options on the
table so remember the public know
what we're discussing it's um if you
could go just um no not all options you
just go up to the top i mean sorry
right to the top i'll do the little
three
i don't know what's wrong with my
equipment right so the recommendations
chairman are that members recommend btc
implements a solution at their cost
utilizing their own information
communications technology provider and
providing funding for their chosen
solution
or that members allocate funding for the
costs of malden district council
officers to implement the preferred
option for as set out in appendix hm
which i've just referred to or that
members review the costs and confirm
that meetings of the south eastern era
planning committee returned to burnham
town council without streaming noting
that this will go against our wider
council decisions practices and could
impact access to meetings chairman thank
you is it yes thank you so much
um
is there any uh
views on this members
council
club yeah thank you chairman i i think
trying to understand this is to look at
what the officers are recommended and
when i first looked at this i thought
they were recommending that we stayed
here chairman so i was delighted to see
the uh
the cost efficiency of option four i
mean if i i don't know
i i i can see uh i can see i think craig
up there but i mean uh and his family
indeed look at that
uh grant
grant holly yeah
um so uh you know option four looks like
it's certainly good value and if it
works and and uh grant is uh confident
that it works chairman um i think we
should go for that unless my friend from
birmingham council says otherwise um i
think that that is probably the the best
option but i do really think german and
it's i do really think that it would be
a great thing to move this committee
back to burnham town council building
because it's something which local
residents
like and i think compared to all of the
other committees including at times
district planning committee more people
go there i think than any other planning
committee chairman thank you so i've
made a proposal and if it's if it's the
right one i'm sure councillors stamp
we'll support
yes thank you um i find myself strangely
in agreement with uh councillor fluke
which is a good thing to do from time it
turns out and uh i would not support
option four it's vital that we get
planning back to burnham it has been
missed there and of course covered as a
reason why it was taken away so yes i
think it's worth the money i don't think
bowentown council of course can
afford it themselves i think it's the
role of district council in such a
situation to support a parish or a town
council so i'm in favor too of option
four thank you councillors
councillor maze
i see you mr stamp yeah thank you mr
chairman um
whilst it sounds a really good idea
i have some reservations
um
why are we making a special case for
south west
well sorry south east i think
um well it's north west i've got
northwest on my mind on my brain um
where north west have equally um travel
issues um with coming into
molden uh district council offices here
which is the home of the council
um i feel that we should have all
meetings here
i understand
why
um
uh burnham
members would like it to be
nearer to them um but it is sort of one
of those things that we take on board
when we sign up on the dotted line
uh it's not something that i'm very
comfortable with and i think it's six
seven thousand in the whole scheme of
things it's not a great deal of money
but it is still six or seven thousand
pounds that could be spent elsewhere
um
rather than on the luxury as i see it at
this point
in taking our planning for southeast
down to to burnham that's what it's like
that's just my just that's just my my
personal view um so thank you very much
for the opportunity
always was at burnham on crouch well
well what you said was was not quite
correct
um the reason it should go back is it it
works counselor fluke was absolutely
spot-on we get absolutely loads of
people who turn up and cancel skins and
bell can and passenger could uh and beal
so i don't leave anybody out
and the new everybody chairman who
attends
um so
i actually would like to um agree
um with uh and i'd already highlighted
it so i'm not actually copying you
councillor fluker but i don't agree it
should be any cost to burnham town
council
um we can support if we you know as much
as we can but it should not be any cost
to us at all
just a very quick one the i just want to
commend the officer for the clarity of
the report um it's a very simple report
that non-technical people like my good
self understand and i just want it
registered that it was very easy for me
as a non-technical person to actually
make a decision based on the information
so i want to say well done and to grant
for for the report and the way that it's
put thank you and it's four thousand
eight hundred not six okay councillor
thompson
thank you chairman um
i must admit i do feel ambivalent about
the cost but i absolutely recognize why
the members of south east feel their
residents are better served by the
meetings down there and my only
observation is about the comment for
north west in northwest we really don't
have a suitable venue otherwise i'd be
pushing for that frankly i think that
would be a brilliant idea
um so i don't disagree with councillor
mays but i think we'd be
schlepping people from tolston we can
bishops all back again and you know the
north west is not and i and and there's
the people from pearly of course sorry
but not from council of white so if it
were practical for north west i'd love
it but honestly it really isn't um
so i think i'm in favor of option four
certainly at the moment thank you
councillor
yeah thank you chairman um
i mean what counselor may seem to have
missed is that historically there was an
extremely good reason why southeast has
been sort of all my
time with this council and i know for
yourself and council brian bill
considerably longer than myself has been
down at burnham and it's because that
burnham
was originally the
its own council looking after its own
area and it the planning was left down
there as part of the democracy that was
retained
for burnham when the main part of the
town council or not the town council the
barricades i believe it was came to
malden district
as other members have said it is an
extremely well attended
committee we do get far more people turn
up for that than for any other committee
that i have seen on this council and
even generally full council itself apart
from
the district planning which at times has
attracted large numbers
and it's been a very good it's it's very
easy not just the local members to
attend but it's very easy for local
people to attend
it's a very
simple way of dealing things and keeping
local democracy local and
my only question would be on this is i
don't know i don't understand enough
about high tech as everybody knows
but
i will stick with option four if that's
the recommendation my only question on
that would be how long is it going to
take to do i don't want to see i would
hope that obviously next thursday is
going to be here but i would hate to
think in six months time we're going to
still be here and being told oh we can't
get the equipment because it's not
available at the minute i mean it's
certainly the case for an awful lot of
stuff and my choice would tend to be the
one that's most available rather than
anything else if that is a major issue
thank you we have uh an expert online uh
councillor who might if we call him in
mr hurley
um to to give an opinion on how long it
might take be helpful
are you
sort of there discussing as well um
hardware wise we can get delivery within
about a week and pursuing approval
um from that point um
we will require up to a given month to
then install the hardware get it tested
and get it working
so that's the right time for it
would this be left in situ
[Music]
uh or would it be returned to these
offices after each meeting
would be left
as with option 5b
we do need to contact bt as well on the
internet line that's currently present
offices
and then can't head to
spacecraft
who forgot next
thank you very much
council fleming thank you chairman um
i i understand why the uh committee
members would like it returned to the
town council i think now isn't perhaps
the best time to do it though i think we
need to be showing that we're saving
every penny
thank you
um
council skanes
again second year i will be brief um i'm
raising the question because i don't
quite get it from this report will it be
will it be possible for this streaming
service to be available to the town
council should they
choose to use it i did ask that question
it will be left in situ i don't know
whether the town council mr hurley
can you answer that
oh sorry
holly
can you answer that
yes for sure
it depends on the location unfortunately
um our biggest pursuit when it comes to
live streaming is the internet
connection available
now as we've seen from the tests we've
done already
the internet connection is a 30-minute
download within a nine-minute upload
in this case it's that nine megabytes
the upload speed sending information
which is the concern
realistically for a decent live stream
um you're looking at at least sort of
those your automated upload speed so we
would have to ensure that the line at
those locations are sufficient to
achieve that stream
um uh thank you councillor oh council
spain did you want to come back on that
just very briefly uh fiverr is coming
into all of burnham and there's every
chance and if it can't happen now the
equipment may be there for the future so
because there will be upload speech when
the fiber gets there if it hasn't
already council swine
yes thank you chairman um yes i don't
see a comparison really between
northwestern south and southeast and um
given the importance of burnham as the
sort of second major
center in the in the um district i think
it's quite
uh reasonable and obviously in
democratic interest from point of view
of public um
involvement um that uh the planning
committee should meet in burnham
um so i i would certainly support this
option for
i think you've got the last word
councillor maze
uh yeah i i still come back to the the
economic situation and the economic
climate that we're currently in and i
still feel it is
[Music]
unpalatable at this particular juncture
to be spending this amount of money on
something that we already have here in
in this i hear what you say about it
being historically down there
um malden district was a huge district
once upon a time
we are now very much the poor relation
to many other districts across the
county so things change
we've had the pandemic we are currently
going through economic and economic
crisis for all sorts of uh families
across the district and i think six
thousand pounds just to be spending on
something like this
um is
it's not something that we should be
doing at this particular moment thank
you very much for your time mr mr
chairman members um i'm i've called i
called councillor mays as the last
speaker on this um
we have a proposition uh that's been
dually seconded
can i ask for a point of clarity because
my understanding is looking at this
report the sum total is one thousand
eight hundred and fifty pounds i mean if
i missed something because councillor
may seems to keep saying it's six
thousand pounds and tony
you know it is it is a lot of money but
we must lose sight of the fact german
but we you know we've got to pay our
costs for calling
out we mustn't keep going back over the
points that have already been last
council you i don't think you've spoken
yet
thank you chairman yeah having having
heard having heard the speeds that uh mr
holly has quoted at the moment
i don't think it's going to be
technically possible to actually do it
so you know in terms of livestreaming
and and i back up what counselor fleming
and councillor mays have said this isn't
the right time
um well this is opening the debate again
i've got hands flying up everywhere
councillor bell
thank you mr chairman the fact that we
don't currently have a high speed
internet might be no more than the fact
we haven't actually asked bt if we can
have fibre i live just around the corner
i've just upgraded it may be available
um i'm hearing it is available
unless unless unless i'm hearing uh
unless i'm hearing some sort of
amendment
um i'm going to put the proposition as
it stands at the moment
um
which council of fluker
proposed that option four be accepted
and that seconded right all those in
favor of option four please show
um
i don't know who else is voting uh one
two accounting i mean one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen could we have a
recorded vote please mr right
doesn't matter
16 17 18 19 20 21 22 23. i think that is
a majority
um
therefore um
option four
uh will be uh provided
uh councillor helm thank you mr chairman
if it helps the members
i'm prepared to vote uh to die up to
2000 pounds of the cost of this
because it's really important that local
democracy works thank you very much and
that's what i stood for and that's why
i'm here talk to mr leslie right
um
uh right
now we go
the vote has been taken it's it's
finished business uh members please no
more yeah mr chairman point award i'd
like my um dissent recorded please thank
you yes
that's proper
thank you
miss bird did you get that
uh gender item 21 business by reason of
special circumstances considered by the
chairman to be urgent i had none
uh 22 exclusion of the press
public and press can i have a resolution
to resolve that under section 100a for
the local government act 1972 the public
be excluded from the meeting for the
following item of business on the ground
that it involves the likely disclosure
of exempt information as defined in
paragraph three of part one of schedule
12a to the act and that this satisfies
the public interest test in relation in
relation to commercial options for
princeton's road can i have a second
surprise
members agree
miss bird switch off please
you